What would be the best right program for bladder infection?
I would have to look at the right. I don't know if there is a cystitis program or one that's
labeled bladder infection. I'd look through the alphabetical list, either of them if I were you.
You can run if it's if most bladder infections
have a bacterial component to them. So running bacterial infection, any bacterial programs may
be helpful. If you've had a test done and known the bacteria, then you can look up and see if
there's a program for that bacteria. If you can't find anything, then I would have to
if you have some labs that show. So it's good to get a lab where they do a smear and they test
for what the culture it is. So getting a culture to know what exactly their treating would be helpful.
If I can find frequencies for that bacteria or fungus, or there's Candida programs for sure
or the right program, that I can write a program. So if you can't find something on the right,
let me know that I might be able to create a program for you. I can't always if there's no
adult frequencies for a specific bacteria. But if there are adult frequencies in the
program that hasn't been created, then I can do that.